Hey Youtubers happy 2017.
There's so much exciting stuff happening,
but Geoff John's just went on this tear announcing
all kinds of stuff like he's writing comics
to get in there just happens to be a new DC
TV show they can announce soon.
So let's talk about what that is starting
2017 off right there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a DC TV related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything.
Happy 2017, everybody, it's gonna be so awesome.
I'll be doing like a superposed with a bunch
of other stuff is going to be coming, but
what is this new DC TV show the way Geoff
John's is talking about it, it sounds like
it's definitely live-action is only one show
that I know about the could drop this year.
If you talking about a show this this year.
Now I said they're going to be announcing
something soon so that could be something
that is coming at 2018, but he just makes
it sound like this is something that will
be able to watch during 2017, so that would
be black lightning just coming from Greg Berlanti
who is like the master of the CW arrow verse.
He was a character on the young justice TV
show.
I know we have young justice season three
coming up, but I don't think that's what Geoff
John's is getting ready to announce, but they
did use him in a Justice league type way on
that TV show tells her he will try to but
if that's the case, even though black lightning
is been part of the Justice league of the
kind of crating TV Justice league in the arrow
verse technically that's a flock show so would
be kind of like Gotham where it's not really
connected to the other DC shows even though
it's kind of connected is a bit weird when
you're talking about shows on other networks
because people always want them to crossover,
but because as different studios like it was
enough trouble to get Supergirl to cross over
with flash.
When it was still at CBS and CVS had an ownership
interest in the CW, so there was even like
a little bit of connection between them.
That doesn't really exist with Fox, but because
Fox has a bunch of DC shows in its own stable
now those can crossover is much as they want
to, so we can talk more about crossover stuff
when they confirm which Syria is the just
a number of other series that they could be
working on there's rumors of teen Titans birds
of prey revival.
Although they have a lot of movie stuff happening
with teen Titans characters in the DC extended
universe, so I'm not really expecting a Titans
show.
At least for a couple more years is totally
possible that they could do that whenever
arrow goes off the air, but I think that has
a couple seasons left in it.
I mean it is my great wish that they would
do a Titans show with characters from the
arrow verse but they also have legends of
tomorrow like they know that Katie Cassidy
is going to be doing some really weird stuff
with the black canary black siren character
in the next couple of years in the arrow verse.
So for the time being legends of tomorrow
is sort of like their catchall show where
they cycle cast in and out.
I'm really hoping they get to that point with
another Titans type show that they could do
like a female spinoff like birds of prey because
they're just so many female characters that
they have in them like the last big birds
of prey TV show wasn't exactly a critical
darling and typically when they're looking
for new shows to do and look for either characters
that have never been done before for like
something that's completely new or they look
to do a better version of characters that
may have been done a disservice in the past.
So birds of prey would be like a high candidate
for that.
So when you look at stuff like the big four
night crossover in the arrow verse the Hall
of Justice the Justice league things that
are happening on the flash right now just
the flash alone.
It just feels like they're laying groundwork
for stuff like that to be happening in the
future but that might be a little further
off than the stuff.
The Geoff John's is talking about this is
enough for this on a close call to myself
over the dominators in the rest the world
alone some simple.
As you can't do this and honor know all filings
you to keep her home safe very not letting
you leave no offense Oliver the human arm
was like you when you accrue roast but if
you're not familiar with the black lightning
character he's originally from suicide slum
in Metropolis.
So there is like a bit of a Superman connection
they change the way his powers have worked
a little bit over the years.
Originally he wore a belt that allowed him
to control electrical field like you can create
electric blasting created for skilled later
they wreck on that he became a metahuman that
was just born with that ability, so he didn't
require any special gear to be able to do
that but he started out in the late 1970s.
So he was a little bit of a black split Tatian
type character you member Luke Cage started
out in the early 1970s.
This was sort of DC's been on a character
like that someone from a very crime alley
type place inside Metropolis decided to use
his powers to make his city his life better
they've never really explained the fullest
extent of his powers, which I think works
to their benefit because they can we surprise
you would like some big act of heroism like
holy crap I didn't know he could do that but
he's mostly been an outsider's Justice league
character the most recent retelling of his
origin story, the black lightning year one
comic book basically reads a little bit like
Luke Cage, so that might be how they treat
the TV show, where he comes back to suicide
slum with or without his family he has a family
in the comics.
They might do them on the TV show, but he
comes back and tries to make it better.
He left because his father was murdered.
So it's like okay this is a crap town.
I'm getting out here but then later he's inspired
by the Justice league people like Superman
to come back and make his neighborhood better.
So he's a street level hero even though he's
been part of the Justice league, so if you
seen the way the Gotham treats you know films
Gotham city like portrays it on screen I'm
expecting the same treatment even though that's
Gotham city and technically black lightning
will be going to Metropolis.
But they haven't confirmed that that just
where he's from in the comics so they might
be using Metropolis on that TV show but it
all just depends on which TV show Geoff John's
is talking about whether or not it's black
lightning or something else is just that I
would be very surprised if there's another
TV show they like stealth develops in are
going to drop this year it just too hard to
do live-action.
That way, so usually what happens is is villanelle
to show the like.
A year later they'll actually have it ready
for you to watch.
But in related DC TV news there is a big change
this coming legends of tomorrow is going to
start hearing on Tuesday nights after the
flash so because that's not happening for
a couple weeks till January 24 they'll be
couple more trailers.
I'll just remind people when I post my next
legends of tomorrow video.
It's going to be a bit of the schedule change,
but I will be doing a 2017 video for like
all the new stuff that's coming in the next
couple of months now for the entire year,
just for the next couple of months because
like Legion for instance of Fox TV shows that
in the X-Men universe is going to be starting
in February that a lot people might not know
about so that video will probably post Monday
morning just like hey you know, happy new
year everybody this is what's happening in
the next couple of months, but in related,
comic book news Benedict Cumberbatch Sherlock
is premiering today episode one.
I'll be doing a video later tonight so be
sure to check that out it'll be fantastic
and I will say congratulations to this week's
flash ring giveaway winner Clint brew please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that starts in this video
I'll just announce the winner the next time
I post a DC video.
So get hype it's going to be an awesome 2017
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the trailer for the next episode
of the flash and you can click here for the
arrow trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!